la guerra del gran y el primer conflicto
en décadas a las puertas de la unión
europea cumple una mesa cerca de 1000
personas han perdido la vida desde que
empezó esta guerra en este país y más de
10 millones han se han visto forzados a
abandonar sus hogares en un datos de
naciones unidas a la población ha vivido
estos días con desazón miedo miles de
niños han tenido que abandonar sus
escuelas y otros tantos han tenido que
aprender a convivir bajo las bombas
rusas junto a sus familias hay ciudades
martirizadas como la asediada mariupol
en el sur del país pero también hardcore
en el este o summit en el norte y
también en quiebra capital de ucrania
los combates siguen siendo intensos
sobre todo en las afueras en futuro
además es incierto las negociaciones en
este momento están estancadas y esa
guerra relámpago que se creía al
principio posible no ha ocurrido
mientras que el gobierno de moscú
todavía no parece estar listo y
marcharse de este país